introducing the underwater jetpack wear
it and freestyle faster than Michael
Phelps eat your heart out Aquaman
anytime you can use technology to give
human beings superpowers I'm all-in
we've paddled to Portsmouth England to
ask inventor Simon Park what prompted
this aquatic awesomeness
I created the underwater jetpack to
enable people to fly underwater really
it's as simple as that
I've always had this kind of passion for
trying to develop the technology that we
were promised as kids but were never
delivered you know you watch the James
Bond movies and really those kind of
things captured my imagination as a
child and I was left as an anti was
saying where's my jetpack where's my
jetpack
there's your jetpack but how does it
work this underwater jetpack is composed
of two thrusters one on each arm which
are powered by two lithium polymer
batteries and a backpack that the
swimmer wears and you control it with a
handheld throttle press the throttle
button and the thrusters power up
driving you through the water these
thrusters work by means of propellers
what Simon has done is encase each
propeller into a special ducting called
a Colt nozzle quart nozzle has a
cross-section much like the wing of an
airplane it's shaped so that as water
moves backwards along its length it gets
through a smaller and smaller aperture
what that means is that the water is
forced to accelerate because water can't
compress that water jets out the back of
the thruster and the user goes screaming
through the water if you've scarred
dived you'll know exactly what it feels
like it's actually even more intense you
know water's a thousand times denser
than air so you know we might only be
doing six or seven miles an hour but
when you scale that speed against air
speed its ferocious I call it underwater
hyperdrive and we call it awesome